so let's talk about the Democrats Mike
Bloomberg is picking up steam despite
not understanding how to pet a dog no
Mikey you do not shake the dog's face
like a human hand oh that's not playing
let's see it one more time okay very
polite dog he's shaking his face I think
he lost the PETA vote meanwhile like
that tiny scar you got from a vaccine
when you're a kid Hillary really never
goes away or heals I bet she still has
the urge I certainly feel the urge
because I feel like the 2016 election
was really an odd an odd time and
outcome and the more we learn the more
that seems to be the case right now
Bernie Sanders is hot and as the most
enthusiastic base so what if Hillary or
anyone somehow knocks him aside what do
you think his voters are gonna do are
thinking about for Mike or Joe they'd
just as soon vote for Trump which would
be hilarious almost as hilarious as
these anti Sanders Dems turning on
Bernie
they're attacking him for this I think
I'll probably vote for Bernie but him as
a human being when I was hanging out
with him and yeah I believed in him I
like him I like him a lot
he's been insanely consistent his entire
life he's basically been saying the same
thing but for the same thing his whole
life and that in and of itself is a very
powerful structure to operate from now
Rogen's right Bernie's been insanely
consistent insanely consistently wrong
while America excelled he only embraced
the world's losers but that's not what
got Rogen in trouble it's because Rogen
is a comic who's made a zillion jokes
over his lifetime some really stupid
some even awful and in this age that
means you're a prime not just for
cancelling of your own career but your
own sins can infect others around you
like someone you endorse say Bernie
offensiveness becomes transmissible like
a virus remember hate the sin love the
sinner
it was one of religions greatest hits
now the sinner is thus in making
forgiveness impossible at least in this
endless game of grievance whack-a-mole
it's not hard to see where this leads it
happened before in 2016 a guy named
Trump wrote in on a PC killing horse if
the left continues this mob action it's
gonna do it again huh Dana kiss heared
the dog expert was that the proper way
to pet a dog shaking the upper roof of
its mouth well I think he was just
playing with the dog that stuff that's
assault no I wouldn't say assault but
also you want to teach kids that before
you just go and put your hand in a dog's
mouth I want to like basically let them
smell your hand to see if it's okay and
it's like asking permission for a hug
right now that whole battle I think they
should have signed a waiver that is
crazy that thought you know that dogs in
therapy now he's got a therapy human you
know when she says the more we learn yes
about the 2016 election and why she has
Richmond that's all about they still
believe that Russian interference cost
them 2016 election and James Comey and
misogyny and husband's telling their
wives how to vote but here I watch
Hillary Clinton and I actually have pity
for her and this week in the New York
Post published an article that the FDA
is approving more MDMA to be used for
PTSD and therapeutic settings which
could be fantastic because Hillary
Clinton clearly suffers from PTSD and
for that I truly feel bad for her
because she wakes up every day every day
is Groundhog Day and it is a living
nightmare for her and and the only way
she can wake up and marry andie
macdowell is if she wins the election
and and she has to somehow figure out a
way before it was having to elbow Liz
Warren out of the way but but she's
already imploding so she may have her
wish and a brokered a brokered
convention I miss Andie MacDowell what
is she maybe I better not Andy come on
out yes won by the way the Hillary then
later said to be fair that she will
support any nominee there is so that
says she may not be running but there
could be a brokered convention and she
could drop from the sky with Michelle
Obama together that's your fantasy yes
I don't know what that is women dropping
from the sky yes
thank you God be careful whose hand is
Dana have to hold her all right
look I was interested in what you're
saying about Joe Rogan because that was
interesting to me about this whole
cancel culture business yeah because I
don't think Rogan is any right-wing no
right-wingers are gonna endorse percent
exactly that's ridiculous
I mean but on the other hand people see
him as part of this dark web into like
the Navy they think he goes off and he
says as you said some really awful jokes
homophobic racist type stuff but the
point I think is you see this now on
both sides these purity test if the
phone call wasn't perfect then you're
not loyal to Donald Trump
if you're not if you're 99% with them
you might as well be zero I mean to me
this is where politics is going it's all
like all or nothing and driven by the
far left and far right and I think Rogan
Rogen should the idea that he supports
Bernie I don't see that that's the prize
you know who we well Rogen's just
collateral damage cuz the knives are out
for Bernie but yes he is a bigger threat
to the Democrats that Donald Trump yeah
how did the Democrats handle 2016 think
about how they'd handle a landslide loss
with Bernie Sanders it's gonna be ugly
and he's gonna want to abolish ice he's
going to raise middle-class taxes take
aware of your health care and give it to
illegal aliens ban fracking Donald Tom
Trump is going to have a field day with
Bernie and the Democrats know it yes in
the New York Times say there's four
articles about how worried the Democrats
are